si vous étiez en centre-ville le tour et
hier en fin d'après-midi alors vous les
avez forcément vu ou entendu 900 motards
de l'ONG United rider déguisée en père
Noël et mobilisé pour Seven près de 6000
euros récoltés pour aider à l'achat d'un
fauteuil roulant s'évan c'est enfant de
8 ans qui souffre d'amiotrophie spinale
une maladie génétique qui le paralyse
peu à peu voyez ce reportage d'Aurélie
Renaud chez lui à Marais dans le Nord
Touraine
ce soir c'est Evan regardera le match de
foot à la télé en attendant il marque
des buts sur sa console puis direction
sa chambre où il nous énumère ses jeux
préférés
des voitures
des Playmobil
les
billes jusqu'à ses 14 mois le petit
garçon marchait sans aide puis la
maladie a été détectée une amyotrophie
spinale de type 2 elle entraîne une
paralysie progressive contre laquelle
savane se bat au quotidien il se pousse
beaucoup il fait du 4 pattes on l'a pas
quotidiennement dans les bras en fait on
lui demande s'il veut aller dans sa
chambre c'est lui qui va il rentre par
terre et de ça mais il le fait de
lui-même donc en fait ça lui permet de
garder le peu de force qu'il a bientôt
c'est Evan aura besoin d'un fauteuil
roulant il faudra aussi un véhicule
adapté la maison devra être réaménagée
car la maladie gagne du terrain des
dépenses importantes plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'euros et peu d'aide au
financement la famille de sayvan a
récemment lancé une association tous
ensemble avec say van vente de brioches
de petits artisanat
le font récoltés serviront à la
recherche et à soutenir la famille parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est important que
c'est vanne à 8 ans puisse aller aux
toilettes tout seul par exemple il a
aussi son autonome fin son propre corps
il a aussi besoin d'intimité sa douche
par exemple donc voilà donc un système
de transfert avec un fauteuil qui puisse
lui permettre d'y aller mais c'est vrai
qu'on se disait que si juste un humain
sur sa planète plus un humain donnait
juste un euro on pourrait y arriver et
qu'aujourd'hui on n'y arrive pas tous
les trois mois c'est Ivan bénéficie d'un
traitement une injection qui permet de
repousser la paralysie tout ce qui a été
relayé par